non è che avete presente quel sito dove
pubblicano le cose segrete su in segreto
ci sono cose anche su di me da fare
invidia l'immagina e ho detto tutto con
questo quindi ragazzi oggi con voi
soffriamo che cazzo scrivono su in
segreto se scrivo la parola fa vj non
avete ancora capito la gravità della
situazione
ve la spiego io donna di 19 anni sto col
mio fidanzato solo perché identico a fa
vj va beh il mio idolo è la persona che
amo veramente è un rompipalle ma quando
scoprono gli schemi e cazzo vuol dire ma
perché va per quale motivo a zia come
cazzo stai messa tu ti sei messa con
questo foro cristiano perché va bene
torna di 15 anni si avete letto bene
l'età e ultimamente un'ossessione fare i
j
eccola da qualche giorno ricominciato a
guardare i suoi video e lo trovo
estremamente eccitante eccitante ma io
ho sbagliato a caricare i video su
youtube dove caricare su un altro you
seriamente mi faccio schifo da sola ogni
volta che apro un solido mi par tour un
sacco di fantasie e non so che fa male
misseri per quale motivo lo apro mio
video a caso e voglio capire se tifo
così but i bagni così ce ne son funziona
grazie avermi dato queste notizie perché
adesso vivo meglio è
gentilissimo sono uno che ama il grande
fa vj è il mio mito il segreto è che
ogni notte quando vado a dormire non ci
riesco prima devo vedere un video di fa
vj c'è adesso si è scoperto che tutti
guardano i video prima di andare a
dormire è la cosa suona abbastanza
brutta perché che chissà che cazzo fate
dopo che la donna diventa un anno e non
lo voglio leggere ragazzi ho paura o
paion io ho il mio fidanzato quando
facciamo l'amore sapevo
mettiamo in sottofondo i video di fa vj
per non farci sentire è partito tutto da
la prima volta che abbiamo scelto un suo
video a caso certo perché per fare
l'amore ma che cazzo fai mettiamo video
a caso su youtube clicchiamo fa vj per
non farsi sentire mentre c'è che poi è
tutto un dire perché sentendo email
borletti orgasmici nei video sembra più
un orgasmo quello che quando [ __ ]
voi adesso è un'abitudine non riusciamo
a fare a meno di avere i suoi video
sotto quelli degli altri non vanno bene
questo vuol dire che anche sotto questo
video in teoria potreste tanto di
carloforte parlo forte che vi aiuto
ragazzi parlo forte mi piace da
impazzire fa vigenti non ne sono
innamorata e nemmeno lo idolatra malo
d'oro mi fa ridere un sacco e mi rilassa
televisioni strane di youtube poi però
purtroppo non è socialmente accettabile
che mi piace quindi devo vedermi video
da sola ragazzo vuol dire non vorresti
mai che dagli eterni dieci anni che
venga un rom per caso e poverina 6
parlavi di quello dicendo socialmente
accettabile però mio cugino di 12 anni
lo segue alla foto con lui sono
invidiosa favorire va aversi a noi ci
possiamo mettere d'accordo lasciamo il
numeretto che magari voglio un fidanzato
e siccome non ce lo dico tutti che sono
fidanzata confavi j
vabbè quindi da adesso in avanti io devo
dire che sono fidanzato con donna di 14
anni per concludere il cerchio l'uomo di
dice ha preso è bellissimo è questo
avevo già letto fermi sono un vicino di
casa del famoso fa vigente lo odio fa un
casino di notte regista e video verso
l'una di notte e non mi fa dormire
non so se essere felice o triste di
essere suo vicino ai miei amici vogliono
sempre venire a casa mia prevedere lo re
solo per questo mi italiano addio
malapianta il culo che poi è bizzarro
perché vivo da solo c'è non o vicini
però è giusto per farvi capire quante
stronzate ci sono scritte su in segreto
donna di 15 anni una volta dissi al mio
ragazzo quando eravamo ancora solo amici
che assomigliava tantissimo fa vj
nicchia solo medaglie a perché mi
somigliava che sono cura dopo qualche
mese che stavamo insieme mi chiese se
stavo con lui su ecco infatti lo sapevo
io mi chiese se stavo con lui solo per
che assomigliava il mio idolo fa vigili
ovviamente gli risposi di no la verità è
che esisto solo perché gli estra
identico valore guarda il lato positivo
zio non avresti mai bombato se non fossi
stato simile a me quanto sta degenerando
questo video e donna li 14 anni vorrei
tanto baciare per cominciare co famiglia
dal era uomo di 21 anni subito dopo
essermi mandati sono tutti così sti
casini se chi dice che subito dopo
essermi masturbato guarda un video di
famiglia i per farmi ammazzare il
piselli in fretta e non tenere il bagno
occupato per noi
sicuramente vero zio però sappiamo anche
tutti che in realtà ti sei masturbato su
maurizio costanzo donna di 14 anni ho
letto di un tizio che faceva i sogni a
puntate beh anche io ho sognato fa vj
che ammazzava tutta la mia classe mi
sono svegliata la seconda puntata quando
mancavano da uccidere io e il mio ex
sto aspettando la terza punta arrivo sia
tranquilla e la tua connessione che non
funziona bene però la terza puntata
arriva da ragazzi questi erano i miei
segreti più divertenti e i miei non i
miei cioè quelli che hanno fatto su di
me ringraziando iddio proviamo a vedere
se c'è qualcosa di carino che non mi
veda protagonista o quell'assurda
necessità di mettermi un paio di scarpe
mentre faccio la cacca senza non ci
riesce mentre faccio
kakà è una madonna
sta mettendo ragazzi non cadono solo
daltonico e non riesco a capire quando i
segreti sono scritti dai maschi dalle
femmine perché la parola uomo non la
distingue un daltonico cosa cazzo legge
al posto di uomo donna mi piace
scoreggiare sotto le lenzuola e
sventolare verso la mia faccia per
odorarli aprirà sfornate
la vita è una menzogna uomo di 18 anni e
da due anni che mia nonna non mi parla
perché ho parato a scopa gravissimo
geniale sono l'amante di questa
bellissima sono davanti dino youtuber
famoso la sua ragazza non sa che me lo
faccio ogni lunedì sera quando ci
vediamo voglio portarglielo via e non so
come fare lo amo da morire ma ancora di
più amo il suo microfono ma che ti fai
delle tipe mentre non lo so li mortacci
uomo di 21 anni tutti i miei amici mi
sfottono per il fatto di essere vergine
il mio segreto ha per anni ho provato ad
avere una ragazza però mi rifiutavano
sempre so che sono brutto ma non riesco
ad accettare l'ipocrisia di certe
ragazze tutte quelle con cui ci ho
provato dicevano a tutti a loro non
importava la bellezza fisica quando
constata v che queste uscivano solo con
i ragazzi più figli ragazzi sono stanco
di essere giudicato uno sfigato mica ho
deciso io di nascere brutto porca
miseria svolta zio io ce l'ho la
soluzione fai lo youtuber sei a posto
lunedì anche se è brutto ma fame the
vengo indietro tutti ho scoperto mia
madre mentre si masturbava guardando le
foto di biagio antonacci dal computer
shock totale
da ragazzino una volta ho fatto una
scoreggia così rumorosa che mia nonna
che era in un'altra stanza è andato a
rispondere al citofono zio michè avanti
applausi la mia ex deviato foto di lei
mentre tromba con il suo ragazzo le ha
inviate a suo padre
minchia che i dolore che sono ragazzine
che può bastare così per oggi volevo
farlo da un posto video solo che avevo
paura di leggere certe cose e fatti era
meglio non farlo spero che non abbiate
messo questo video di sottofondo mentre
vi fate cose e quando ha iniziato a
farlo youtuber non era proprio questo il
mio scopo scopo però che vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un like serve piaciuto lasciate
un like per quei poveretti che si
ascoltano me mentre fanno le cose anche
la pagina di facebook e come la
trascrizione sui servizi tecnici vi
diavolo possiamo vito belle ragazze